[Music]
it's III 2018 I'm here with gash and we
just played a little bit of Super Smash
Bros both of us are huge fans and we've
been very excited for this game right
off the bat you played as Ridley I think
that's what people really want to know
about yes what was playing as him like
Ridley was amazing like he reminded me a
lot of Charizard from the Wii U version
and that he would that you know he had a
little bit of floaty ability but he had
from like fans is like ion cannons and
that he was very strong like almost -
okey Gary yeah you also got the final
smash with him which is kind of cool
yeah like I actually was able to connect
it on our second match and it was a
really cool way to connect but it
actually felt more difficult to land
yeah it seems like that's just kind of
with all the characters it seems like so
we normally don't play with final smash
or the Smash Ball however it seems like
they are much tougher to land in this
cuz even I got it with I think Marth and
I thought I was perfectly lined up
flat-out meant like I mean it looked
like I hit but I missed
yeah like the hitbox is much more narrow
so you have to be much more precise on
your landing it like even if they're
lined up right if they're too far you
can miss yeah I also got a chance to
play champion link and champion link is
actually surprisingly different from
regular link there's still a lot of
similar moves like his up and B is still
the sword spam yeah but he has the
remote montt or remote bombs from breath
of the wild now which I think are really
cool because what I do is I throw it and
I just leave it there and eventually
eventually someone will pick it up and I
detonate it and I noticed the damage and
blast radius of these bombs are much
better however the good news is if you
saw the direct you know that if you want
old link back I think young link is
gonna kind of fill that role yeah I
actually felt like the same way they're
doing this link they're trying to
minimize the amount of potent characters
and then even though everyone's
returning I feel like they're retooling
a lot of the characters and that's why
in this build they had a lot of possible
clones not exist and even if it were
like Captain Falcon and Ganondorf
yeah Ganondorf is very different this
yeah huh he was very different who's
much more fluid much more nimble like in
some way like Captain Falcon but his
moveset jet felt much more unique and
much more diverse yeah he's got a sword
- yeah he got a furnace time but he
still got that power which you know
black 52 Captain Falcon he make some of
that power but he felt much more viable
yeah and overall having played tons of
smash bros wiiu tons of melee tons of
brawl how would you say this one feels
compared to the other ones
I would favor remind me the most of the
Wii U one but it felt I think you were
saying this earlier it felt a lot
tighter like it felt like the controls
were much more precise and you had to be
a little more skill to really pull off
from the combo but they did make it more
accessible to newcomers as well like the
short hops which are a much more
advanced technique or now something
anybody can pull off as it's part of the
regular booth so yeah you can also do
directional air dodges which we saw in
the in the direct as well however I
think both of us kind of walked away
like what what are we gonna use this for
I like playing it I didn't really seen
opportunities where I'm like oh man I
wish I'd died the other direction
instead of that way cuz I feel like if I
just dodge in the air I'll probably
dodge it but hopefully hopefully we
figure that out soon anything else that
stood out from Smash Bros that you can
think of uh no I'm just looking forward
to seeing more of the characters and
seeing how the gamecube controller plays
with it cuz we got to play with the pro
controllers and well for me I know
you're more of a pro controller guy for
me it felt a little bit weird so I'm
looking forward to seeing how the game
controller does work with it to see if
it does play Jeff like I did with the
Wii U yeah so that was our thoughts on
super smash bros ultimate for [ __ ] III
2018 and more on Super Smash Bros you're
already in the right place
[Music]